[Applause]
hundreds of protesters shouted no police
no curfew as they march through the
capital Mogadishu on Saturday they say
the shooting of a civilian by a police
officer and forcing a curfew on Friday
night is another example of violence and
abuse by the security forces which they
say happens too often this demonstration
will continue until the government
senior officials listen to the outcry of
the population we want the government to
reverse the curfew decisions that is
imposed on the residents during this
holy month the shooting happened near
the headquarters of the Somali National
Intelligence and Security Agency
Somalia's police chief fired the
commissioner in charge of the area on
Saturday and the mayor of Mogadishu
apologized for the shooting first I
respect that the youth of Mogadishu need
to express their anger for the killing
of a civilian they have the right to do
so secondly I'm very sorry for us and I
share the same sorrow you are feeling
Somalia has poor health care facilities
and a limited capacity to trace and test
those infected with the corona virus the
government introduced a lockdown more
than two weeks ago as the number of
people infected with kovat 19:00
increased but there has to be trust
between the public and the police for it
to work effectively and that's in short
supply victoria Gaytan b al jazeera